[Applause]  they're ready for you ready for what  sold-out comedy show that's tonight  their chant your name you can hear that  - yes that chant plays in my head on a  loop 24 hours a day seven days a week  you really need to get going mr. O'Brien  time to enter Oh laughs Oh laughs OH  see I am the center of the zone and I  radiate laughter because I make the left  it happened you know I mean because I'm  in the center of the of the like I guess  forementioned  zone yeah you think I should go that'd  be great  yeah Conan and friends stand up to her  18 cities 40,000 tickets sold 804 people  satisfied and one beer company that  helped bring it all to life Sam Adams